[Music]
welcome to the google cloud
security showcase a special web series
where we will focus on security use
cases
that customers can solve with google
cloud
my name is megan yahya and i'm product
manager
at google cloud today we'll be walking
through one of the top questions we get
from customers
how can i detect network-based threats
in my google cloud environment
cloud ideas is google cloud's
network-based threat detection
technology
that detects malware spyware command and
control attacks
and many other classes of exploits
it provides fully managed network threat
detection
with high levels of security efficacy
and low noise
it's quick and easy to deploy fully
managed
scaled and operated by google with high
performance
and availability built in we have
partnered
with our friends at palo alto networks
to embed
their industry-leading threat detection
technologies
to make sure we have leading detection
both in breadth of coverage and efficacy
backed by their expert production proven
technologies
and world-class threat intelligence
teams
here is a proud overview of how cloud
ideas works
cloud ideas is a fully managed cloud
native product
that receives the mirrored traffic from
customers network
and runs threat detection technology
from palo alto networks
under the hood cloud ideas may be
applied
via packet mirroring to any and all
traffic
to or from a workload whether it's a
compute engine in gce
or a container in gke cloud ideas
moves threat detection closer to the
workload
not just vpc to internet or vpc to vpc
but also intravpc traffic are inspected
for full north south and east-west
visibility and detection
this dramatically simplifies the
fulfillment of the ideas requirement
common to several compliance marks it
also fills in the east-west
blind spots suffered by most socs
in cloud environments cloud ideas
also integrates with soar which is the
security orchestration
and automated response solutions such as
palo alto network's
xor product this enables customers
to set up automated threat responses
based on cloud ideas as alerts
we have built integrations with
third-party siem solutions
which provide security information and
event management to our customers
leveraging these partner solutions in
conjunction with cloud ideas
gives customers additional visibility
into network threats
and security analytics on cloud ideas
alerts
we are also building integrations with
chronicles security analytics platform
and scc the security management platform
on gcp
now let me show you how you can use
cloud ideas
to detect network-based threats in your
google cloud
environment here is how cloud ideas
looks like
inside gcp environment it is located
under network security section next to
cloud armor
and ssl policies products once you click
on cloud ideas
it browse you to the dashboard page
where you can see a summary of top
threads
and ip addresses that have been detected
within your alerts you can customize the
dashboard
using the time filters at the top by
selecting the time period
you're interested in
in order to get started you first need
to create cloud ids endpoints
an endpoint is a cluster of vms that are
running palo alto network's
threat detection technology under the
hood
so first i enter the endpoint name
then enter the network that you want to
inspect
if you have a shared vpc this would be
the host project
cloud ids creates a paired vpc network
attached to the network you specify here
the next step allows you to specify
minimum threat severity alerts you would
like to see
such as low and above
where low is for minor threats with
little impact
on organizations infrastructure and
critical
is a serious alert
once you create this endpoint you're
gonna see it under endpoints tab
now you have an ids endpoint that is
ready to receive
and inspect traffic and generate threats
but it is not receiving
any traffic yet until you attach a
packet mirroring policy to it
that will mirror the traffic from the
associated vpc
click attach to test to set up your
packet mirroring policy
now traffic from the specified source is
mirrored to the ids endpoint for
inspection
so you give the policy a name
and you pick the mirrored sources
and you press submit
the policy is going to show up next to
your endpoint
such as this policy that i had created
before
and that's it now you have your end
point and you have the packet mirroring
policy
so the traffic is flowing to the end
point
and the detection is happening so you
can go to the threads tab
to see the reported threads the time
filter on top allows you to view threads
for a specific time period
you can also use the filter menu to
filter by other thread properties such
as severity
or source ip addresses
you can now click on a specific thread
to get
more details about that thread
once you click on view thread details
it's going to take you to details page
stretch details page
also shows the application based on
application identification
technology app id it also shows you
information about the cv
severity threat type and more
description about the alert
if you go back you can see that you
alternatively you can clear click on
view thread logs
that will take you to a new tab with
threat information
in cloud logging cloud logging
also enables downstream integrations
with your same tools
such as splunk or soar tools such as
palo alto
xor you can also create custom workflows
to take remediation action based on
alerts such as creating a cloud function
that triggers on an alert and generates
a firewall rule to block the ip address
thank you for tuning in please visit
cloud.google.com
forward slash security for more content
from google cloud experts